[Music]
a massive solar storm erupts on the sun
sending billions of energetic
electrically charged particles hurtling
towards earth
interfering with satellites
disrupting navigational systems
knocking out power grids
sounds like science fiction
[Music]
it's not
solar activity is ultimately having an
impact on our technologies that we use
every day
it's the job of research scientist robin
fiore to study the behavior of the sun
and provide a warning system for when
something big is about to take place
so whenever there's a magnetic storm and
we have an explosion of energetic
particles coming from the sun these will
interact with the earth's magnetic field
they call it a coronal mass ejection or
cme and the visible manifestation is a
beautiful aurora borealis
but not everything is pretty about their
impact
they cause a strong perturbation that
can cause currents to be induced in long
conductors like power systems and the
impacts of this can be quite wide
ranging from voltage fluctuations within
operating parameters to more extreme
events where we would see a blackout of
the system
charged particles from solar flares are
pulled in by the earth's magnetic field
and drawn towards the north and south
pole so we are at a greater risk canada
is one of the countries that's most
vulnerable to the impacts of solar
activity and space weather
this keeps fiori and her colleagues at
the canadian hazards information service
busy so we have satellites located near
and above the earth and we have
ground-based instruments as well and
these help us to look at the impacts of
the solar activity on our magnetic field
and also on the upper atmosphere and
ionosphere so that we can look at
potential impacts to the systems on and
near the earth
it's about to get a lot more energetic
solar activity occurs in 11 year cycles
and we are now moving from a minimum
activity level to a maximum one
we're starting to see more and more
activity and we're starting to expect
the potential for more impacts to some
of these sensitive systems
[Music]
power grids are one of those systems
with over 4 million customers hydro
quebec is acutely aware of the risks
so how many people would this service we
met with louis gibson an engineer from
hydro quebec in march 1989 there was a
big uh solar storm and it took the power
of either quebec so we had a blackout
and to this day this is the biggest
impact a solar storm had on any
electrical utility
so this for us was a wake-up call and we
had to take this matter very seriously
since then
that power failure forced the public
utility to install safety equipment to
protect the system from sudden
electrical surges caused by storms
and they regularly run simulation
scenarios to test everything
when you say this was a wake-up call
explain that this was a wake-up call for
the entire industry so there is a
standard in place now in north america
where the electrical utilities have to
make sure they have to plan and prepare
the network so they can withstand a 1 in
100 year event solar storm event for
this we get help from
various space weather experts
that one in a 100 year storm is what
everyone worries about
one already happened in 1859 known as
the carrington event it was a storm so
big that it literally set telegraph
wires on fire
it could happen again and most likely
will but this time it will impact a lot
more than just our power grids
[Music]
energetic particles coming from the sun
can directly impact satellites causing
disruptions to their operation even
causing the satellites to become
disabled or reducing the lifespan of the
satellites
recently there's been talk of how
critical cables running under the sea
might also be at risk
in the uk tony frisch is the chief
technical officer for xterra a provider
of international subsea fiber optic
systems these cables are the things that
you use when you're doing a zoom call
when you're surfing on the internet and
you're trying to get content from one
country to another there's probably
enough cable in the seas to go around
the world about 30 to 50 times
there's a component of these cables
known as a repeater that is particularly
sensitive to solar activity
we have
some very expensive power equipment
which provides the power for the
submerged electronics and that drives
current all the way through the center
of the cable if you had a really big
storm event that could induce
quite large current to go through the
cable one of the problems with a cable
like this is that it's
in a sense the worst possible thing that
you could have it's very long so lots of
current could get induced in it
but frisch believes there's a solution
if you knew that there was an event
coming
you would in fact turn the cable system
down and disconnect it until you were
sure that that event was finished
because the good thing about these
really extreme events is that you get
some warning for them
a one to three day warning in fact
thanks to the work of researchers like
fiori
that's the role of the canadian hazards
information service because space
weather is a hazard it's a hazard of the
technological age right so this is this
is why we perform this research as well
you